[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه هو من
جميع الجوانب
16 احدث وعود الغرب الاكياج بوتن تحت ضغط
التحرك السريع والترامب يتحدث عن جنون يجب
وقفه
ان التنسيق الامني مع حكومه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لم يعد قائما اعتبارا من الان
ني ويتوجه بالملف للجنائيه الدوليه وبينكن
يستعد لزياره تهنئه
مع قرع الطبول الانتخابات اردوغان يزيد
انفاقه والمعارضه تسير في حقل الغامق
قانونيه لترشيح منافس
وتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
اختيار موقع السفاره هنا في غرب لندن قد
يثير العديد من التساؤلات لكنه وفر ايضا
العربيه
في لندن بسبب هدوء البالغ وتحفظ السكنيه
سفاره كم يونغ اون
تدفقت الاسلحه على اوكرانيا منذ اشهر
الحرب الاولى لكنها الان باتت كالسيل الذي
لا يتوقف وسائل الاعلام ايطاليه تحدثت عن
ان روما سترسل انظمه دفاعيه مضاده
للطائرات الى كاف اضافه الى مسيرات
اسرائيليه الصنع وقطع مدفعيه ثقيله
ومدرعات وذخيره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اما وزير الدفاع البريطانيه
بلاده تعمل في وصول دبابات تشالنجر
بريطانيا اعلنت انها سترسل 14 من دباباتها
القتاليه الرئيسيه الى جانب الدعم مدفعين
اضافيين لاوكرانيا
هذا هو اعتبرت الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان لا
فرنسا ولا اي من شركائها في حاله حرب مع
روسيا وقالت المتحدثه باسم الوزاره
ان تسليم المعدات العسكريه في اطار ممارسه
الدفاع المشروع لا يشكل انخراطا في الحرب
في المقابله قال المتحدث
ان كل ما يفعله حلف الناتو في اوكرانيا هو
مشاركه مباشره في الحرب
هناك تصريحات مستمره من عواصم اوروبيه
واشنطن بان ارسال انظمه واسلحه مختلفه الى
اوكرانيا بما في ذلك الدبابات لا يعني باي
حال تورط هذه الدول او التحالف في الاعمال
العدائيه في اوكرانيا وفي موسكو ينظر الى
كل ما يفعله الحلف على انه مشاركه مباشره
في الصراع نحن نرى ان هذا اخذ فلسطين
اوكرانيا بتجنيد عدد من المجرمين على
اراضيها بوحشيه ودفعهم للموت في هذه الحرب
وفي اول تعليق له وبعد قرار ارسال
الدبابات لاوكرانيا من امريكا ودول
الغربيه قال الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب قال ان امداد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات يهددوا بحرب نوويه وقال انه يجب
انهاء هذه الحرب المجنونه الان مضيفا من
السهل انهائها الان قبل ان تنطلق
اذا هكذا يختار المعسكر الغربي الاصطفاف
بشكل كلي الى جانب اوكرانيا بموافقه
المانيا وامريكا على ارسال دباباتها
الثقيله في خطوه قد تدق ربما اخر مسمار في
نعش المفاوضات مواقف حلفاء اوكرانيا باتت
اكثر وضوحا من خلال ابداء استعداد اكبر في
دعمك عسكريا ما تعتبره موسكو دخولا مباشره
الالمانيه وابرز الامريكيه وغيرها قد تكون
مجرده ايضا من صيدا فالاوربيون
والامريكيون عازمون على ضخ المزيد من
الاسلحه للجيش الاوكراني فبعد الدعم البري
يسير حلفاء اوكرانيا الى التوجه الان نحو
الدعم الجوي وعلى غرار صفقه الدبابات يبدو
ان الولايات المتحده تخطط لارسال مقاتلات
اف 16 لاوكرانيا ضمن سيناريو مشابه
لسناريو الدبابات وذلك نقلا عن موقع دي
درايف الموقع افاده بوجود مؤشرات عن تمهيد
لمثل هذا القرار من بينها زياره طيارين
اوكرانيين للولايات المتحده من اجل التدرب
على طائرات افسته عشر وما يزيد من
التكهنات حول ملف المقاتلات هو اعلان شركه
لوكيد مارتن المصنعه للطائرات عن
استعدادها لتلبيه طلبات الامداد
[موسيقى]
هي الدبابه الاقوى في العالم نتحدث عن
دبابات ابرامز التي هي في طريقها الى
اوكرانيا اذا لتحدثان نقل نوعيه حقيقيه
على مستوى العتاد الاوكراني الاوكرانيا
حبست انفاسها قبل سماع كلمات الرئيس
الامريكي وهو يعلن ارساله 31 دبابات
ابرامز الى اوكرانيا في قرار لم يكن سهلا
بالنسبه لي بايضا بهذا الخصوص كشفت صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز النقاب عن الكواليس التي
سبقت اتخاذ هذا القرار اعلان سبقته
مفاوضات مطوله بين واشنطن وبرلين تحديدا
التي كانت بدورها متردده في ارسال دبابات
لكن عوامل عده غيرت مجرى الاحداث اولها
التطورات التي حدثت على ارض المعركه في ظل
التكثيف موسكو لحجماتها في الفتره الماضيه
ما اعطاها التفوق النسبيا النقطه الثانيه
هي رغبته في عدم السماح بحدوث شرخ في صفوف
المعسكر الغربي الذي عرف نوعا من التصدع
بسبب ملف الدبابات تحديدا وهو ما اكده
ايضا من خلال قوله اردنا التاكد من اننا
جميعا معا لكن يبدو ان فرنسا ليست معه على
الاقل حتى الان المزيد مع زينه عدي
لا تستبعد باريس تسليم دبابات لوكلير
القتاليه الثقيله لاوكرانيا من اجل دعمها
في الحرب ضد روسيا لكن اتخاذ قرار نهائيا
في ذلك يحتاج وقتا والاسباب عديده اهمها
بان تصميم هذه الدبابه يعتبر معقدا عن
التكلفه ثم ان عدده هذه الدبابات التي
صنعت محدودا في فرنسا ما يشكل عائقا كبيرا
في حال الحاجه الى صيانتها وتمتلك هيئه
الاركان العامه الفرنسيه اسطولا من لوكليت
مكونا 226 دبابه وهو عدد محدود خاصه ان
الستين في المئه منها فقط جاهزه للاستخدام
وما تبقى يستخدم في التدريبات من باريس
عادي
[موسيقى]
لا على الاطلاق من المؤكد ان الدعم
العسكريه لاوكرانيا لن يضعف فرنسا فلديها
ما يكفي من الاسلحه ولن يضعف الدول
الاوروبيه او امريكا
دعم اوكرانيا بالاسلحه بات شعار المرحله
القادمه بالنسبه للغرب فالموضوع بلغ حد
التفكير في انشائي مصانع للاسلحه خصيصا
لتلبيه حاجيات اوكرانيا الفكره اقترحها
رئيس لجنه الدفاع في مجلس العموم
البريطاني توبياس الود وبرر فكرته بتضاؤل
مخزونات الاسلحه الغربيه فضلا على ان
الفكره ستمنح الجيش الاوكراني استقلاليه
اكبر عروب عبد الحق معها المزيد من
التفاصيل حوله هذا المقترح
انت ماشي مع التحركات الاخيره لدعم
اوكرانيا في مواجهتها العسكريه مع القوات
الروسيه دعا رئيس اللجنه البرلمانيه
المكلفه بشؤون الدفاع الى بناء مصنع
للاسلحه في بولندا كجزء من خطه طويله
الامد لتجهيز اوكرانيا بالاسلحه والمعدات
العسكريه واعتبر النائب في حزب المحافظين
ترابيس انا تردد الغرب في تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمعدات العسكريه يعكس ضعفا في رؤيه
الاستراتيجيه الغربيه كما ان تجويدها بعدد
المحدود من الدبابات امر جيد الا انه ليس
حلا مستداما وفق تعبيره وبحسب قلب فانا ان
شاء الله مصنع للاسلحه في هولندا سيساعد
اوكرانيا في كسب استقلاليه عسكريه من
ناحيه ضمان الامدادات كاشفا ان المحادثات
بدات للفعل مع فولندا لانشائي مصنع قادر
على انتاج دبابات من نوع الالمانيه
والنتيجه بحسب تكون تقليل الضغط الذي
يواجهه الغرب لتوفير احت اوكرانيا وحمايه
مخازنها من الاستنجاء
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه يجب ان ندعم اوكرانيا بشكل كبير
نحن ننتمي لعلم واحد ويجب ان نساعد بقدر
ما نستطيع
وكما نعلم فالاسلحه جزء من عالم التجاره
ولا اعلم اذا ما كنا نريد فعلا ان ندعم
ذلك في النزاعات اليوم افضل ان نساعد
الافراد
ومن كل قلبي ادعم اوكرانيا ثم اناس يدفعون
حياتهم ثمنا وهو اقل ما نستطيع فعله وانا
ادعم كل جهدا في سبيل تحقيق ذلك
وسط هذا الخطام يطرح السؤال الكبير كيف
سيتعامل بوتين مع كل هذه التطورات التي
تقوي بشكل كبير موقفه اوكرانيا في الحرب
خطط كثيره لوح بها بوت منذ بدايه تعقد
المعركه غير ان العامل الزمني سيكون هذه
المره حاسما ساموسكو مدعوه الى التعجيل في
تنفيذ خطتها في اسرع وقت ممكن الخيار
الاول هو الاسرع في حل مشكله
التعداد تعداد الجيش الروسي فرقنا قرار
التعبئه الجزئيه فضلا عن الاستنجاد بقوه
فاجنر وقوات جيش الشيشان الا ان الجيش
الروسي مطالب بحشد اعدد اكبر الحل الثاني
المتاح في وجه بوتن هو الاستفاده من
الموقع الجغرافي لحلفته بلا روسيا الجار
الشماليه لاوكرانيا حيث نشرت موسكو قواتها
على ارضها اما الخيار الثالث فهو الذي
يبقى الاصعب والاخطر وهو اللجوء الى
السلاح النووي التكتيكي الذي لوحد به
روسيا في الكثيري من المناسبه ومن فيينا
ينضم الينا ضيفنا من هناك وولف جانج باست
ستاي المحلل في الشؤون السياسيه والامبياء
اهلا بك معنا سيد ولف جونج يعني الا يعتبر
تسليم هذه الدبابات الهجوميه لاوكرانيا
انخراطا مباشره من قبل الغرب في هذه الحرب
الدائره تحديدا ومباشره ضد روسيا
سعود
الغربيه بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده تقدم
السياحه الى اوكرانيه منذ اكثر من عام من
الزمن
والاهميه الاساسيه
لتقديم هذه الدبابات المتطوره تكمن في
جانب بانها سوف تعزز معنويات الجنود
الاوكرانيين ومن جهه اخرى من شانها ان
تساعد اوكرانيا ان تحافظ على الخطوط
الاماميه وان تقوم بعمليات هجوميه وهذا
الامر يعتقد على يعتمد على العمليه
الهجوميه التي تنوي روسنها في فصل الربيع
هذه الدبابات
هجوميه واسعه النطاق من قبل الاخرانيين من
اجل استعاده الاراضي المختصبه
وبالتالي كيف سترد موسكو برايك على ذلك
وهي التي حذرت برلين اكثر من مره من
تزويدي اثنين
يشعر بغضب بالبالغ لكننا لا نتوقع من
روسيا ان تستخدمه السلاح النووي السلاح
النوويه يعتبر من قبل روسيا يعتبر بانه هو
الملجا الاخير
بالنسبه الي دبابات فهي سوف تكون
القوات الروسيه لكن روسيه قد تستخدمه
السلاح النووي
اذا اضطرت
في اوكرانيا
يمكن ان تستخدم روسي
الى هزيمه كبيره في الروسيا في اوكرانيا
فهذا الامر يحتاج الى اكثر من الدبابات من
ناحيه اخرى لابد للروس ان يكون على دراعي
انه اذا ما تم استخدام السلاح النوويه
فسوف يكون هناك جدا كبير من قبل نيته وهذا
الرد سوف يكون تقليديا من جانب النيدو اي
بمعنى بانه سوف يكون هناك ضربات موجه على
كافه القوات الروسيه
المحليه لاوكرانيا وهذا من شانه ان يفضي
الى نتائج مهمه وسوف يحدث اضرار كبيره
بالقوات الروسيه وسوف
يبقي الازمات
متكرره وتتوالدوا في روسيا
الوسطى وفي جورجيا وغيرها من المناطق مثل
هذه الخساره العسكريه المدويه
ايضا قوه الجيش الروسيه
سوف
يفكرون مرتين قبل استخدام السلاح النوويه
لافراف صراحه في تصريح منذ ساعات بان
الخطوط الحمر عند روسيا سقطت بفعل
القرارات الامريكيه وايضا الالمانيه همم
الا يعني ذلك سياسيا ودفاعيا وعسكريا انه
حتى الخطوط الحمر التي وضعتها روسيا
بالايام الماضيه وبالاشهر الماضيه قد تسقط
ايضا
ما هي الخطوط الحمراء بالنسبه
له هي مساله التلاحم بين قوه التحالف وقد
اظهر هذا التحالف من خلال مناقشه المطوله
حول تقديم دبابات حاله من الوحده لدى ان
الروس يدركونا
بنفس الوقت لتقويضي
اما في ميدان المعركه فقط تكون الامور
مختلفه
مساله تهديد سياسي فقط وليس اكثر من ذلك
الحديث
[موسيقى]
جديد السيد يعني هناك حديث بريطانيا عن
انشاء مصنع للاسلحه في بولندا الكيا فقط
مخصص كل ما يصنعه ليذهب الى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ما حقيقه هذا المصنع وماكلفته
عليكم
تابوني الشمس
بقدر كبير من الامدادات بما في ذلك دقائق
و الدبابات
الدفاع الجوي لدم من باب الحكمه ان يتم
تاسيسه نوع من التسهيلات او المصانع
لتقديم هذه المتطلبات الاوكرانيه لكن من
الواضح ليست هذا ليست هذه هي الحقيقه التي
قد تتجلى خلال بعض اشهر قليله بالنسبه
لانشاء مصنع للذخائر الامر قد يستغرق
سنوات هذا قد يكون الالتزاما طويلا الامد
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا وهذا ما كانت طالبت به
اوكرانيا في ظل حربها
شكرا جزيلا لك
المحلل في الشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا ولكن بعد الفاصل
حرب وقضاه لبنان مستمره النائب العام يحي
القادم انفجار المرفا لتفتيش القضائي
ومجلس القضاء الاعلى يرفع يده مؤقتا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وقبل الذهاب الى ملف
زياره انسولين بلينكن الاعلام الروسي
يتحدث عن انفجارات قويه بالقرب من محطه
زبورتجه النوويه التي تسيطر عليها منذ
اشهر القوات الروسيه اذا اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الوزير سيتوجه الى
الشرق الاوسط الاسبوع القادم للحافي على
وقف اعمال العنف اعمال
العمليه الاسرائيليه في جنين
برايس المتحدث باسم الخارجيه يلتقي رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتانيا هو
الرئيس الفلسطيني
وكانت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه اوقفت التنسيق
الامني مع اسرائيل وقررت التوجه بملف جنين
للجنائي الدوليه واسفلت العمليه
الاسرائيليه عن مقتل 10 فلسطينيين واصابه
عشرات اخرين وخلفت فوضك كبيره
اليوم
في ضوء العدوان المتكرر على ابناء الشعبنا
والضرب الحائط للاتفاقات الموقع بما فيها
الامنيه نعتبر ان التنسيق الامني مع حكومه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم يعد قائما اعتبارا
من الان
عندنا التنسيق الامني ما حكومه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لم يعد قائما اعتبارا من الان
قوه اسرائيليه خاصه تدخل بزي المدني مخيم
جنين عند السابعه صباحا بعد اكتشاف امرها
وتعرضها لاطلاق النار من مسلحين فلسطينيين
اجتاح الجيش الاسرائيلي المخيم واقع عددا
من الضحايا بين قتيل وجريح
بعد ساعه على انسحاب الجيش الاسرائيلي من
مخيم جنين بقيت دخان المتقاعد من هذا
المنزل شاهد على اربع ساعات من الاشتباكات
والانفجارات التي عمت احياء مخيم جنين
خلال اجتياح الجيش الاسرائيلي للمخيم
ومحاصره المنازل
الاتحاد
الدور وبلش اطلاق انا ارجع على البيت
احتجز في البيت اللي تحت هذا البيت
احتجزوا فيه اصحاب البيت
وقعدوه مسكره علوم البيت وبلشوا من البيت
نفسه يضربوا ونرجع البيت هذا الصواريخ
الاسرائيلي فيما لا يزال العشرات يتلقون
العلاج في المشاكل الفلسطينيه وصفت جراح
اربعه منهم بالحرجه
لتصدر المشهد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه في
عمليه وصفت بالاعنه في منذ تولي الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده زمام الحكم في
اسرائيل ما ينظروا بتصعيد خطير على صعيد
الصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
العربيه
حول اقتحام اسرائيلي مخيم جنين ينضم الينا
من الناصره المحلل السياسي نظير مجالي
اهلا بك سيد نظير يعني قرار الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه بالتوجه الى الجنائيه الدوليه
الى اي مدى هذا القرار
سيغير بشيء يعني ما حكومه من الواضح ما هي
السياسه التي ستنتجها بالقاده من الايام
قرارات
تتعلق في العلاقات الاسرائيليه الفلسطينيه
واضح ان كل توجه للمحكمه العليا يزيد من
الغضب والغضا الاسرائيلي اتجاه السلطه
الفلسطينيه هنالك عيدا الوقت نسيت الامني
وعدد من الاجراءات الاخرى يعني من الصعب
ان نقول انها ستؤثر بشكل مباشر على
القياده الاسرائيليه خصوصا وان الكثير من
الاجراءات الاسرائيليه في المناطق المحتله
تتم لحسابات اخرى والحسابات مختلفه بعيده
عن قضيه الصراع نفسك يعني من همم من غير
همم المفاجئ لنا ان نرى ان نسمع ضباطا في
الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدثون اليوم عن ان هذه
العمليه هي اثبات على ان ما يقوله اليمين
المتطرف من ان الحكومه او الجيش لا يتخذ
قرارات بقتل اولئك الذين يهددون الجيش
الثبات اليوم اننا لا نخاف ونصر القارات
بالقتل من دون اي مشكله فمثلا هذه
الحسابات داخليه بين
جيش الاسرائيلي وبين
يمين المتطرف وخصوصا الوزير سيموتريتش
الذي جاء الى وزاره الامن الاسرائيليه لكي
يشدد من اجراءات اطلاق النار
فتجدد يعني حسابات داخليه في اسرائيل هي
لا تتاثر ابدا من معركه في الخارج
يعني هل يحاول نتنياهو تصدير المشكلات
السياسيه الداخليه وحتى القضيه همم سيدنا
نظير ابقى معي همم نتوجه لان نشاهد هذه
الصور المباشره لاستقبال الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون
محمد الشاعر
محمد شاعر السوداني رئيس الوزراء العراقي
في زياره رسميه الى العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس
من الناصره اعود اليك يعني عن المشكلات
الداخليه
الاسرائيليه هل يحاول نتنياهو تصديرها الى
جنين من خلال عمليه الاقتحام هذه
والاحتجاجات
بالشوارع الاسرائيليه
همم بنعرف ان هو في سنه 2012 عندما خرج
400.000 متظاهر الى الشوارع في اسرائيل ضد
السياسه الاقتصاديه ورفعوا شعار الشعب
يريد اسقاط النظام في حينه اقامه باجراء
اقتصادي معين ولكن اذا اضافه الى ذلك عشان
حربا على غزه هذه العاده موجوده في
السياسه الاسرائيليه لكننا في هذه الحاله
نتحدث عن الصراع داخلي بالحكومه
الاسرائيليه بين الجيش الذي همم تحاول
الحكومه سحب صلاحيات من والتسليمها الى
سموتش همم احد قاده الاحزاب الاستيطانيه
في اسرائيل الذي يطالب همم زياده الحزم
بين قوسين يعني كل ما يجري في المناطق
الفلسطينيه
طبعا بتولي كل المسؤوليه عن الضغط الغربيا
والجيش يقول ان هذا سحب هذه الصلاحيات هو
غير قانوني وسيورد اسرائيل في امم اخرى
ويؤكد انه حاجه الى ان يسلم هذه الصلاحيات
لانه يقوم بواجبه بالشكل اللازم والضربه
الى مخيم جنين قد تكون اسبابها بيبحثون عن
هذه الخليه او تلك ولكن باستسهال قتل تسعه
اشخاص في ان واحد بينهم امراه مسنه
والدخول الى هذا المعسكر المعسكر اللاجئين
الذي يعتبر من اكثر المناطق ازدحاما في
العالم الدخول بمائه القوات وضرب صواريخ
وليس فقط رشاشات صواريخ الى البيوت لقتل
اولئك الناس هذا يعني همم يعتبر شيء همم
مبالغ فيه بدون شك
يؤدي الى تصعيد وهم يعرفون ان هذا تصعيد
ويقولون ان الجيش قام بتصعيد محسوم
في الزياره المرتقبه همم الى همم
للقاء الرئيس عباس كما تحدثت الخارج
امريكيه هو لقاء الجانب الاسرائيلي هل يجب
وضع خطوط حمراء جديده على الجانب
الاسرائيلي عدم عدم تخطيها ام ماذا
خطوط حمراء
في المناطق المحتله منذ حوالي سنتين وهذا
التصعيد ادى حتى الان الى قتل حوالي 240
فلسطينيه وفي هذا الشهر وحده 30 فلسطينيا
المشاريع المخططه لتستيطان وتوسيع الشيطان
واعطاء شرعيه للبقر الاستيطانيه يوم الاحد
القادم سا- تجتمع الحكومه لاكرار مجموعه
من القرارات
يعني هذا التصعيد مستمر ومن دون شك يوجد
حد حاجه لوضع حد هذا همم لهذه السياسيه في
الوقت الحاضر والاداره الامريكيه يتعاملون
بمساواه بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
همم يعني لا ياخذون بعين اعتبار ان هناك
احتلال احتلال يحاول ان يكرر نفسه ويقدم
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وضمها الى اسرائيل
مقابل هنائك الذين يدافعون عن انفسهم
باقسط الادوات يعني نحن نتحدث عن عمليه
ثلاث ساعات مئات الجنود الاسرائيليين لم
يجرح منهم من جندي اسرائيلي وعد كل
الخسائر والاصابات كانت في الصف الفلسطيني
مما يعني ان هناك حرب غير متكافئه ينبغي
بدون شك ان تتوقف والا فان الاوضاع ستنفجر
بشكل او صعب
هل تتوقع ان يحدث على المستوى الشعبي على
الاقل ومواجهه جديده في ظل يعني همم قيام
الجيش الاسرائيلي برفع حاله التاهب في
قطاع غزه
الى الشوارع عاده لما انتفض الشعب
الفلسطيني كانت امامه قياده موحده يسير
وراء بفكر كامله اليوم توجد عند كسمات
عديده فلسطينيه
الى الخروج مسيرات شعبيه وهبه شعبيه ومع
ذلك يعني لا توجد منطقه تقريبا فلسطينيه
الا وفيها
نوع من المقاومه الشعبيه للاحتلال همم
بالنسبه لغزه هناك حماس يعني كما يبدو
انها اتخذت قرارا بان لا تصعد
والنقاش يجري الان او الضغوط تمارس على
الجهاد الاسلامي بان لا يصعد في قطاع غزه
اسرائيل من جهته اعلن تعدد وانزلت صور
بطاريات صواريخ القبه الحديديه لمواجهه
احتمال التصعيد هذه الليله وهمم هنالك
جهود همم تشارك فيها ايضا الولايات
المتحده لكي لا يكون سعيد ولكن اليه قال
انه مستعد للتجاوب مع هو لا يريد التصعيد
ولكنه
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من الناصر المحلل
السياسي نظير مجالي
[موسيقى]
اذان مشاهدينا اكدت الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه ما اعلنه وتحدث عنه الاعلام
الروسي منذ قليل عن وقوع انفجارات قويه
خارج محطه زبرجيا النوويه الى لبنان حيث
اجل مجلس القضاء الاعلى جلسته للبث في
قضيه المحقق في قضيه انفجار مرفا بيروت
طارق البيطار وقالت وسائل الاعلام لبنانيه
ان التاجيل جاء بعد رفض نصف اعضاء المجلس
عقد الاجتماع بسبب الاجواء المتوتره شعبيه
اخلاء سبيل الموقفين في القضيه
هذا واكد نواب لبنانيون تايدهم للقاضي
بتاره مطالبين مجلس القضاء الاعلى بموقف
واضح من قرارات مدعي عام التمييز القادم
الثانوي
وهو هلا بيشتمع وهو بيقرر مصير شو بصير
بعيد كلنا علينا مسؤوليه استرداد الدوله
من الدول كلنا علينا مسؤوليه استرجاع
ملفى من الضياع ومن العرقلي
ثواني بقى ومن تهديد القاضي بيطار طلبنا
من المعالي وزير العدل ان يقوم بواجباته
ايضا ضمن صلاحياته اللي بيعطيها القانون
الى اقصى حد لكن للاسف ووجهنا بتصرف
ميليشياوي من حراس الوزير يلي ضربوا
النواب اللي كانوا موجودين بهذا الاجتماع
فاجتنا الرساله واضحه من السلطه التنفيذيه
حقها للضحايا اصحاب
[موسيقى]
لا حديثه في الاوساط التركيه سوى عن
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقبله
التي يتطلع اليها الاتراك والعالم على حد
سواء بترقب كبير ارتباط اسم تركيا بالعديد
من الملفات الخارجيه يجعل المجتمع الدولي
ينتظر ما ستصفر عنه هذه الانتخابات فكيف
يستعد اردوغان الى هذه المعركه التي
اعترفت المعارضه ان ترشح لها او اعتبرت
المعارضه ان ترشحه لها هو مخالف للدستور
الحكومه التركيه بقياده اردوغان وقبل اشهر
من الانتخابات
اجراءات لاستماله الناخبين تقول صحيفه
واشنطوس الامريكيه نقلا عنعارضا اواخر
ديسمبر الماضي رفع اردوغان الحد الادنى
للاجور بنسبه
55% لم تكن هذه الخطوه الاولى من نوعها
قبل مده ليست بالبعيده اقرت الحكومه برامج
لتقديم الدعم النقدي للاسر ذات الدخل
المنخفض فضلا عن التمويل الذي تم تق
لحمايه الودائع بالعمله المحليه منخفاض
قيمتها معارض اردوغان يوجهون له ايضا تهمه
محاوله ابعاد السياسيين باستخدام سلاح
المتابعه القضائيه ابرز هذه المتابعات
الحكم على رئيس مدينه اسطنبول رئيس
البلديه اكرم امام اوغلو بالسجن سنتين
وسبعه اشهر مع حضره من ممارسه الانشطه
السياسيه بتهمه اهانه مسؤولين وترى
المعارضه ان هذا الحكم جاء لاقصاء امام
اوغلو من الانتخابات خاصه وانه بات يملك
شعبيه كبيره في البلاد وكان اغلو المنتمي
لحزب الشعب الجمهوري قد نجح في الحاق
هزيمه قاسيه بحزب العداله والتنميه سنه
2019 بفظه على مرشحه وقت ناس منصب رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول
ارى ان هناك خلافا داخل الطاوله السداسيه
ولن يخرج بنتائج ايجابيه يعني التي هناك
عده خيارات داخل طويله السداسيه من سوريا
واش اكرم امام اوغلو وكمال كيلتش دار
اوغلو هو في مقدمه المرشحين براي ان
ثلاثتهم لا يستطيعون منافسه اردوغان
لا يوجد لديهم مرشح رويدا رويدا بدات
الخلافات تظهر بينهم لا يوجد بينهم منافس
لاردوغان
المعارضه
في الوقت الراهن على الاقل حيث انها لم
تستقر بعد على مرشحها مما يثير تكه هناك
عن امكانيه وجود انقسامات داخليه من شانها
ان تشتت مجهودتها بعيدا عن المنافسه مع
المعارضه فانا حظوظ الرئيس التركي قد
تتاثر ايضا بملفات اخرى بعد خسارته بعض
المعارك الاقتصاديه بسبب قراراته التي
اثرت الوضع الداخلي للبلاد من بين ابرز
النقاط السلبيه التي برزت التراجع الكبير
لقيمه العمله المحليه التي فقدت نحو ثلثي
قيمتها مقابل الدولار في العامين الماضين
اقتصاديا بلغ التضخم على اساس سنوي نحو
85% في نوفمبر الماضي في اعلى نسبه تسجل
في تركيا منذ اكثر من 25 عاما وينضم الينا
من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه زيدان زنكلو
اهلا بك زيدان يعني ما ابرز ما جاء في
بيان المعارضه التركيه
نعم لا شك ان ملف الاول او النقطه
الاساسيه التي جاءت في البيان هو موضوع
امكانيه او قانونيه ترشح الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان للمره الثالثه بيان
المعارضه ان اعتبر ان هذا الترشح مخالف
للدستور ما لم يتم اقرار هذا الترشح من
البرلمان بشكل قانوني ودستوري طبعا هذه
كانت النقطه الاولى في هذا البيان الذي
اشار ايضا الى سعي المعارضه او جهود
المعارضه ما زال مستمره لاختيار مرشح
وهناك معايير وفق البيان يجري همم سيتم
همم الاقتداء بهذه المعايير للوصول الى
المرشح الذي تنتظره اوساط المعارضه ايضا
بين الامور التي تحدث عنها البيان الختامي
موضوع المرحله الانتقاليه وكيفيه اداره
هذه المرحله الانتقاليه حيث تخطط المعارضه
الى التحول من النظام الرئاسي المعمول به
حاليا الى النظام البرلماني القديم الذي
كان قبل عام 2017 ثم جلست بدال هذا النظام
بالنظام الرئاسي الذي يعطي الرئيس صلاحيات
واسعه بناء على استفتاء في ابريل عام 2017
المعارضه تريد العوده الى النظام
البرلماني لذلك هناك مرحله انتقاليه في
حال فازت بالانتخابات
للعوده الى هذا النظام ومن ضمن طبعا او
خطوات المرحله الانتقاليه هو ما يتم نقاشه
في اجتماع الطاوله السداسيه الحادي عشر
الذي شهدته العاصمه انقر هذا اليوم لكن
بالعموم همم هذا الاجتماع الذي استمر تسع
ساعات لم يخرج همم بنتيجه واضحه وصريحه
حوله هويه المرشح المحتمل وعلى ما يبدو ان
هناك عده نقاط ليس فقط المرشح المشترك
للمعارضه هو السبب الرئيس في همم موضوع
الخلاف انما شكل الحكم كيف سيكون في حال
فازت المعارضه اي اليه اتخاذ القرارات من
قبل الرئيس هناك عده خيارات مطروحه مثلا
ان يكون الرئيس من حزب الشعب الجمهوري
ويكون باقي اعضاء الطاوله السداسيه نواب
له من ضمن الخيارات ايضا ان يكون الرئيس
من حزب الشعب الجمهوري كون هذا الحزب هو
الاكبر بين احزاب المعارضه من حيث القاعده
الجماهيريه وعدد المقاعد في البرلمان ومن
ثم يكون نائب الرئيس هو من حزب الخير ثاني
اكبر احزاب المعارضه في الشارع وايضا في
البرلمان ومن ثم بقيه الاحزاب تكون لها
وزارات في الحكومه كل هذه النقاط جرى
بحثها وفق مصادر همم موافقه مصادر معارضه
في اجتماع اليوم
عن الاسم الذي يحظى شعبيه الاتراك من
ناحيه المعارضه وايضا ااه اطراف الطاوله
السداسيه لم يتم الاعلام طبعا عن اسم حتى
الان من هو الاسم الاكثر ترجيحا برايك
وفقا المعطيات التي ظهرت خلال الايام
الماضيه يبدو ان زعيم المعارضه كماكن
الجدار اوغلو هو من هو الذي سيتقدم الى
الترشح وهو كان اعلن في اكثر من مناسبه
بشكل غير مباشره انه يرغب بالترشح وعارض
بشده ترشح اكرم امام اوغلو رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول وايضا منصور رئيس بلديه انقره رغم
ان استطلاعات الراي كانت تعطي هذين
الاسمين نسبه اصوات اكثر من نسبه اصوات
التي من المحتمل ان ينالها زعيم المعارضه
لكن زعيم المعارضه اثر ورفض ترشحه هؤلاء
همم رؤساء البلديهات وهذا ما خلق خلافا
داخل الطاوله السداسيه لكن حتى الان يعني
يبدو ان الامور تتجه الى ترشيح كما كل
الجداره الاساسيه مع ان وفد رؤساء بلديات
المعارضه يوم امس زار كما كشجار اوغلو في
مكتبه وكان من بين الوفد اكرم رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول ورئيس بلديه انقره من سوريا هذا
همم الوفد اكد دعمه ل همم كلش دار اوغلو
توقيت الزياره كان جدا مهم قبل اجتماع
الطاوله السداسيه هذا سيقوي موقف كلي جدار
اوغلو امام بقيه احزاب المعارضه لدعمه
للترشح كمرشح مشترك عن المعارضه
ولكن باختصار شديد همم اردوغان رفع الحد
الادنى دعم الاسر منخفضه الدخل حسب
استطلاعات الراي وحسب ما ترى في الشارع من
نبض الشارع هل هذه الاغراءات يمكن ان تؤثر
في مزاج الناخب التركي سريعا لو سمحت
الى حد ما يمكن ان تؤثر لا سيما انها
ترتبط بسياسه خارجيا تهجها اردوغان منذ
العام الماضي وهي موضوع تصفير المشاكل
ودور الوساطه الذي قام به في حرب
الاوكراني لذلك حتى الان استطلاعات الراي
ما زالت تعطيه افضليه على
كمايكل جدار اوغلو المرشح المحتمل
للمعارضه
من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
تثير السفاره كوريا الشماليه الواقعه في
شارع سكنيين غربي لندن مخاوف عده سكان حول
هذه المنطقه بسبب الاجراءات الامنيه التي
تتبعها وايضا بسبب اتخاذها مقر لها في حي
سكن كما ذكرنا مصطفى زارو ذهب وزار موقع
السفاره المثيره
من يلقي نظره سريعه على هذا المنزل لا
يجده مختلفا عن اي منزل اخر في هذا الشرعي
بضواحي غرب لندن باستثناء ساريه العلم
ولوحه السياره الدبلوماسيه
العلم لكوريا الشماليه والمنزل المكون من
سبع غرف يعود لصفارتها في لندن على عكس
السفاره الاخرى التي تتخذ من الاحياء
الراقيه كميثر وكنزا مقر لها
كاميرات مثبته في كل ركن من اركان المنزل
السفاره تثير مخاوف سكان هذا الشارع الذي
يبلغ متوسط سعر المنزل فيه
750 الف جنيه
الى وجودها في هذه الضحك السكنيه
لهذا الموقع لا يقلقني لا يزعجونني ولا
ازعجهم
كما نظام وكينج جون اون يحافظ ديبلوماسيو
وسفاره على سمعه بلدهم لناحيه السريه
الجديده لكنهم يختلطان في بعض المناسبات
مع عامه الناس فيما يظلون بعيدين كل البعد
عن اماكن اقامه السفراء الدول الاخرى
الاكثر فخامه في وسط لندن
اختيار موقع السفاره هنا في غرب لندن قد
يثير العديد من التساؤلات لكنه وفر ايضا
على بينغاره باهضه على مدار 20 عاما
فالمال كان احدا العوامل الرئيسيه لاختيار
ضواحي العاصمه بحسب نائب سفير صادق انشق
عن النظام قبل ست سنوات ليلجا الى كوريا
الجنوبيه
في تركيا اعطيني عمرا وارميني في بحيره
ملاسيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
اعاده حسابات الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب على موقع فيسبوك انستقرام
بعد حظر ان استمر علينا خطوه ستساعد ترامب
على التواصل مع مؤيدين هو جمع الاموال
لحمله الانتخابيه ناديه البلبيسي
حسابات ترامب المعلقه على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تعود اليه واحده تلو الاخرى قبل
ايام من انطلاق اول فعاليه انتخابيه له من
مدينه كولومبيا في ولايه ساسكارولا
[موسيقى]
من استخدامها لتمويل حملته الانتخابيه
والتواصل مع قاعده مخلصه التي بقيت معه
واعلنت ولا اهتم لهم
فورمات كويس
السابق ترامب يريد اعاده تنشيط حسابات على
فيسبوك او انستغرام او تويتر لانه يمتلك
شركه تواصل اجتماعي خاصه بها وهي تروس
سوشيلا لذلك فهو لا يريد بالضروره ان يقود
المتابعين الى النايل سات اخرى وبالتالي
مساعده الاخرين على كسب المال متابعوا
ترامب على الفيسبوك ووصلوا الى 34 مليون
متابعا اما انستغرام فالرقم وتعدى 23
مليون
صادر عن شركه متى الملكه لفيسبوك
وانستجرام تحدثت عن الحاجه الى ضمان حريه
التعبير وتبادل الافكار وان قرار التعليق
جاء في ظروف اضطراريه والظرف الاضطراري هو
احداث السادس من يناير حيث اتهم الرئيس
ترامب بتحريض مؤيده على مهاجمه مبنى
الكابيتال امر شكل صدمه للام ومنذ ذلك
الوقت وحسابات الرئيس ترامب معلقه ولم
يكتب اي شيء حتى الان منذ السادس من يناير
اما ترامب فقال لا ينبغي منع اي رئيس
مجددا من استخدام وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وعبر حسابه في تروس سوشيال قال ان فيسبوك
الذي خسر مليارات الدولارات من قيمته منذ
حظر رئيسكم المفضل الذي هو انا والكلام
لترامب اعلن للتو انه سيعيد تفعيله حسابي
ناديه البلبيسه العربيه وعشان الى تصريح
اليوم لم اتخيل ابدا
الذي رايته التصريح والي مديره احدى
الجمعيات الخيريه في منطقه حاكني شرق لندن
التي اضافت ان العام الماضي كان فضيعا على
الامهات والاطفال بسبب التضخم لكن ان كان
هذا الحديث يقال عن شرق لندن فماذا يقال
عن الكونغو اوتي
اليوم اعطني عمرا وارميني في البحر هذا ما
عايشه سبعه ركاب مع سائق حافله هم في
تركيا بعد ان اختلت عجلات القياده بين
يديه لتسقط الحافله بمن فيها في احدى
بحيرات مالاتيا سجلت كاميرات المراقبه في
الحافله لحظات هلا السائق والركاب ولحسن
الحظ لم يوصف الا ثلاثه باصابه خفيفه لكن
بالتاكيد ستبقى الذكر تطاردهم طويلا
الى صوره اليوم من اسرائيل يسترجع ان
نجونا المفترضون مما يعرف بالهول كاست
ذكرياتهم يساعدهم تقنيون في تكوين صور
خياليه اقرب لما عايشوه لحظات الحزن على
فراق الاحبه والهلع على مصيرهم يبذلون
ويبذل معهم التقنيون جهدا كبيرا للوصول
لصوره اقرب الى الحقيقه بينما لو ارادوا
صورا حقيقيه
لوجدوها اليوم تحديدا في مخيم الجنين
ملفاتنا تحت لليوم ولكن المزيد من الاخبار
والملفات مع الزميله ميسون واخبار الساعه
مساء الخير ميسون مساء الخير راويه طبعا
في اخبار الساعه اليوم العديد من الملفات
ابرزها طبعا روسيا واوكرانيا وتطورات
الميدانيه في اوكرانيا ايضا الاحداث في
جنين والجدل الحاصل في لبنان حول القضاء
وتحقيق انفجار بيروت دائما كل معنا
[موسيقى]